hey I'm counting down until we start
reading
we
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
like I've been walking
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
good morning Millennials you need a myth
welcome a the morning toast the morning
breath
today you something you're knocking out
the dream guy no never and I said it to
bed yesterday you know Ben thinks he's
like a songwriter and he was like oh my
god that's horrible
um but then he obviously tried to
rewrite it as like an indie Goo Goo
Dolls song and it wasn't terrible I just
like I can't help a feeling you're
pulling a prank on us no I think it's
actually a great idea for a song but if
you guys don't then I'll just I'll just
your touch with it was it was definitely
a good idea for like a bit for the show
and like we appreciate you know the
comedic flair you bring to the show I am
quite comedic leaf Larry yeah you've got
a lot of flair and I've got a lot of
inflammation yeah but it's gonna be a no
for me doc are you wearing new merch I
am wearing numerous so this is the
Rolling Stones crop t-shirt I tucked it
in today so you can't see that it's
cropped but it's so [ __ ] cute like
obviously I order fixed I wanted it but
it's cuter than I thought it was gonna
be right like that color pink is so
[ __ ] clean II it's good stuff man I
don't think anyone has ever tucked in a
Rolling Stone crop top I mean we're
talking a crime or it was a pair of
trousers whoo guys how high my pants are
is that I could tuck in a crop top
that's crazy yeah that's when you know
you have a problem you know what I'm
just a serious businesswoman breasts in
the shop I want and the job I have you
ever your culottes don't you remember
and I miss those culottes every day I
love them I have them but like they did
me not one favor not one not one favor I
guess maybe the only favor they did is
that I was comfortable yeah that's a big
favor I was a little too comfortable I
agree
well the guy looks like like a you know
I don't know there's our new toasters
like if you watch episodes from like
what eight months it was the first day
of the a year ago Oh a year ago like
Jackie just went through the stage in
here in three months ago given three
months ago 15 months ago Jackie went
through the stage where like she wore
these like oversized culottes that like
Alexa Chung wears you know yeah and
she's like she tongue and I'm five foot
right it was just a no for me dog and if
you don't look good in any capacity
sometimes like things don't look good in
real life but they do look good on the
show I agree like I have a pair for the
opposite yeah I'm therapy
I was gonna wear today but like they
were so unflattering and they would have
looked great on the show because he
wouldn't have seen but we afterwards
yeah and like I just you know what my
sister's being like oh our sister has a
Fupa like how do we tell her yeah I mean
if you haven't told me yet we wouldn't
have told you but I have that same
problem it's like everything I wear
looks amazing in my life but on the show
it just like isn't captured well I think
I need to start wearing pants again
having my thigh out like every day it's
just it's a little too breve for me yeah
I hear you
uh well Tongass so just giving them out
like we just talked about fall for a
minute we can't how [ __ ]
excited I am I don't know I've been
enjoying summer I feel like it's just
whizzed right by me this is actually the
first summer at along which thing it's
gone so fast I feel like summer hasn't
even started yet you've been working so
much but like I feel like as we just got
back from a two-week vacation I feel
like this is the first summer where I'm
not like morbidly obese and I just have
to say like it still sucks
like I still have chub rub I still have
underboob sweat like I'm truly ready I'm
not even ready for fall I'm ready for
[ __ ] winter because it's second day
less I would say there's more options
for clothing okay I just have a really
hard time finding like shorts that
didn't make me want to die so it's a
little easier but I don't know oh it's
all the same yeah it's tough no matter
why it's tough no matter what I thought
this was gonna be like my good summer
you know did you miss a girl I don't
know like I thought this was gonna be
the summer of my life was it on oh you
look like you're having a great time I
guess but like it just I thought it was
like this for me I mean like all your
other friends and have real jobs like
you were really having a great summer I
guess I know but like what happened what
do I have to show for it like it's a
damn aside from vacation actually I used
k'kaw body say the highlighter of the
foundation um
the highlighter cuz I couldn't get the
foundation okay and I don't know I shine
like the top of the Chrysler Building
but sometimes Chinese are good I
actually find that in all the housewives
reunions they all have like super shiny
oily legs and it's kind of like a sleek
sexy look yeah and this is a housewives
reunion
yeah honestly the Real Housewives of
Beverly Hills ringing and they had these
chairs but in couch versions Oh hark
back to Provence
right they really did a good job of
actually we just recently found that out
I don't know if we said that on the show
someone told us that each reunion set is
designed to like mimic or be inspired by
the destination they took the trip on
Erica Jane told us that Oh
what an interesting piece of information
an interesting factoid at its core at
its core like if you were to look up
interesting factoids in addiction in our
dictionary it would be a definition and
there would be see example like a chain
this factoid because now I notice it all
the time like the real houses of Atlanta
had a koi pond in the middle of their
set and the court kept jumping outs
because they went to Japan amazing also
I feel like publications are always
writing up like things you didn't know
about yeah housewives were a bachelor
and it's like they always write the same
things that we actually all do know
because the ocean but that's a factoid
not only we have yeah so I think that's
interesting but that's see just this
whole summer thing because I know I'm
really reflecting on my summer and a lot
of people are having what they're
calling hot girls summers do you think
you're having a girl summer I am oh for
sure because I'm the skinniest I've been
in a long time because there's no like
your little why do you associate hot was
skinny
because she's my because she's terrible
mentality a product of this society you
can't fault her nor a byproduct of
Victoria's Secret I guess but I just I
feel I can say do like I honestly and
looking my best
the healthiest have been my chin is
snatched and I've just been getting like
absolute garbage this summer like
physically feel it I just feel like we
haven't really immersed ourselves in
summer culture like net this weekend we
are so h and i are heading out east and
we have a big weekend plan and i no idea
how much foam i have like the one
weekend I actually a plan I can't
believe like you haven't dropped your
plans because they do I was expecting
you to I think it's gonna have fun yeah
I know but I have like a really great
weekend plan ahead in Vermont okay do
what you have to do
puck but I just feel like we let july
pass us by I think for August we should
make an August resolution that we
embrace the summer guys okay I had an
idea that nobody like really wanted to
like I was gonna make all the plans but
I really wanted to go see the
OneRepublic on Red Rocks and get a house
in Colorado for the weekend you ever
heard that plan no me too but we found a
problem with that by the way I think
it's just one that it was on a Monday I
would do that in a heartbeat podcast I
think we should [ __ ] podcast from the
amphitheater hello yeah what you a live
show at Red Rocks
Millennials I think we should see whose
eyes it's like super hard like totally
totally I think I just want to make the
most of every weekend like we're going
to add a very first show and like we're
making the most like we have a house
with a pool you know what I thought of a
plan for Asbury that I will confer with
you later on um I think it's exactly
what we're gonna need for the Seanie
vibes at Asbury Park okay I think I know
what you're talking about really I think
what do you think well I'm not gonna say
it's nothing crazy oh they just oh it's
just me someone's name hope to bring
with us know who lives there and I think
she has country club membership and
she's very girls okay great yeah I'm all
about the Country Club vibes this summer
like it's like I am country clubs are
the Queen and I'm the sorry people looks
like no one's letting me in I'm taking
recommendations actually I'm now and I'm
spending I was very specific when I set
out on my journey to join a country club
there was one I wanted to join and they
don't want to have me so you don't [ __ ]
them because I heard they're going
bankrupt anyway so I'm now opening my
horizons please let me know
recommendations of this is what I want
another country club like I don't want
it to be like overpopulated with members
like I can't get to see it at the pool
but it definitely needs to have a pool
bonus points for being pet friendly but
it's not a deal-breaker and they just
need to be known for having like
excellent grilled cheese you know yeah
and when I'm there like I want an escape
like I don't want to see you know
airplanes and like I don't want to see
the city skyline yeah I just want to be
in it look at they have golf obviously
that's an extra bonus for Ben but again
I'm not making my wagon they have some
cow for your man FM if they don't have
golfing means they don't have a golf
course which means they don't have big
grounds which means I'm looking for 22
cityscape yeah I'm looking for major
grounds ground control to major snitch
yeah speaking of snitch
did you guys watch bachelor in paradise
last night yes yes and we are not gonna
recap it today for two reasons one
because there is an episode tonight and
two because tomorrow is the official
launch date of the snatchler margos very
own TNN podcast all things bachelor
bachelorette bachelor in paradise we are
gonna be joining some episodes you'll
have your own guess it is your show but
you'll never be on it alone because
that's so scary um but we're gonna be
recapping this all for you do it this
week why I do have to be I don't know oh
okay this week we'll drop an episode
like Wednesday and we will all be on it
together to kick off the snatchler
episode will be uttering paradise right
episode will be up on iTunes
some point today so just stay tuned for
that and it's all gonna be very exciting
and I plan on watching back from
paradise the whole season I enjoyed last
night also I did something before so I
because of the Tyler CGG of it all and
now that it's really part of the
conversation I just wanted to understand
more about him and Hanna and the why
people ship him in Hanna so I watched
the fantasy suite episode of Hannah
Brown season where she brought fort I
called you I wanted to understand I
didn't ask me I called you but you
didn't pick up no doubt it I was already
on to my next question
ooo what do you want me to explain how
come four guys went to think so the
hometowns she just couldn't pick one so
she was just like I need more time I
need another week you're all staying and
people were pissed because we had to sit
through another week so long of just
like who's going home who's going home
and then nobody went home that was
really annoying but like whatever it was
fine he's actually still crazy cuz I
guess that she had like a much deeper
connection with more people than usual
so much said that she had to keep for
where it's like usually when there's 303
fantasy suites like you really know that
the top two but said she had four that
she couldn't part with and she picks the
worse one yeah I didn't watching that I
feel like I got to see her relationships
with all of the guys and the key players
and like Luke P like adios amigo uh I
feel as though she should have picked
ultimately Peter the pilot that's what
mother says he was just like they had
such a real relationship like I
understood the Tyler see like he is
handsome it's like this gift of a man
and maybe he's capable of being a real
person but it but it's hard for people
who look like that I think that episode
of 30 rock though it's Jon Hamm when
it's yeah you don't live in this world
when you're that beautiful it's like you
get treated differently you can't be in
a relationship with that kind of person
I could understand why she didn't feel
like it could be real I yeah that's no
saying Jen I know no I think II was the
shortest Peter like I've been saying
this forever
Peter and Hannah are the ones that make
the absolute most sense like these are
people with the name Peter who got on
that show because obviously they just
get like those [ __ ] end of the stick
yeah that wasn't that was me
also he wasn't yeah he looks like a
combination of Nick vile and Colton
Underwood which i think is like the
dream guy for Hannah be yeah yeah I mean
back to last night's bachelor in
paradise because this is the first full
episode of bachelor that I've watched I
think maybe in like a year may actually
I did much about
Colten season towards the end but um and
it really wasn't as treacherous bachelor
paradise is such a better show better
for me there's so much more going on but
really not that much happened last night
they were taking first of all I have a
really big I know we're not recapping it
but I just want to say really unfair of
them till I give intros to certain
people and not other people because I do
look I know who had a G is like she
doesn't mean an intro yeah like there
were so many people who just showed up
and I was like wait who are you yeah and
like it's helpful when they were at like
from Colton season but like we need more
I like Demi from Demi season I know sexy
Demi and honestly I ship her and Derek I
think they're super cute and that's it's
hard for me to say that because you know
that I am I ship Derek and tisha I ship
literally anyone in Taoiseach a
Taoiseach is a hot girl of paradise
she's everyone's not everyone's here to
having hot girls everyone say like
everyone's here I thinks how did she I'm
like really I don't see that I see
everyone wanting tisha any like the
teachers like involved in the blade
drama but she's like above it you know
yeah and she didn't come back from her
date like oh we're together why yeah he
should have talked to me before he went
on another eight and when when she found
out that blood that Christina asked him
out on the date she's like that's fun
look at normal reaction like I went on a
date with someone I'm not married to
them now total okay we're yeah easier
for the snatchler if you want to hear us
continue these conversations and I have
so many more thoughts also art group
chat last night while we were watching
was so funny we need to just like read
it off oh yeah in on the podcast
snatcher will be up today search it on
the podcast or subscribe so you don't
miss any episodes I'm actually excited
to just talk about this junk for like
ever
okay but get back we took one more
second about too much business about
your hot girls summer what you guys
doing this weekend like that you have
planned
I know Sunday is bright young at surf
Lodge so we're spending the weekend at
Margot's no I know but like to have any
other plans well before certified right
we're gonna go to Gurney's might be cute
and then Saturday like we're definitely
play some kind of sat Margo's and like I
think we're gonna go to a nice dinner
Saturday night well Jonah we're really
cute again
yeah and I just got on my toast merch
and it was all made for this weekend
like I got my visor to play tennis it's
so cute I got two bucket hats because
Zach like really wanted a bucket hat so
that is such a bucket hat cat I got he
really is so we'll be twinning in our
bucket hats I was going to yeah [ __ ]
hopefully she has a flagpole cuz I'm
gonna raise that morning toast flag I've
been to the house and actually there
might be a flag there might be a
flagpole so I just think it's gonna be
toasty it's
meet seen any scheduled a close she's a
little becoming no okay well that makes
me feel better yeah so boy you're so tan
thank you like your legs
well I sat in the Sun this weekend oh
yeah must be nice it was nice
you're the queen and where the sorry
people okay basically I think it's
starting I feel as though it might be
time to deliver the fast five stories
that you need to know before you wake up
and take a bite out of your morning
toast so it's definitely time and I
don't want to you know get crazy or
anything but I would be absolutely
remiss heartbroken devastated saddened
if I didn't let you guys know that
today's episode is brought to you by
Jackie's favorite podcast sponsor
roommate it's one of my favorite prop
it's definitely my favorite podcast
sponsor in the kitchen category okay
that's there okay roommates mission is
to shake up the beverage industry for
the better they're stylish insulated
drink ware is designed to keep your
favorite beverages ice-cold all day so
when when trying to achieve your hot
girls summer it's necessary that you
have a beverage in hand truly hopefully
one with alcohol and roommate just keeps
any beverage like super cold which is so
hard these days like me and learn or a
council a drinking beer especially the
summer and a warm beer is just not the
same as a cold beer now I know why
there's so many songs about long neck
ice-cold beers that never broke your
heart
right I think will definitely never
break your heart if it's in a brew mate
because it will always be ice-cold
honestly I think a good like crossover
for a brew made to work with flu combs
yeah and like literally just have that
song playing in their commercial or
something cuz it's so true like a nice
cool beer literally never broke my heart
and thanks to brew mate you'll never
have a warm beer right and maybe if it
got more and they would break your heart
right that you then you wouldn't have to
worry they're dishwasher safe they have
so many designs Jackie is a pink one I
have a black one because I lack like my
soul and their dishwasher safe to say
they're a date because that's the most
important part yeah okay don't settle
for warm alcohol or any beverage chill
out with your favourite drinks all day
long all summer long with brew mate
visit brew mate calm and add the code
morning to get 15% off your first order
that's 15% off your first order when you
go to be are you ma te comm and add the
code morning love it you guys that's
what you need for your hot Co summer
that's what would make our summers like
feel like summer we're gonna bring our
roommates this weekend snitch hell yeah
and we're gonna have long neck ice cold
Sancerre I won't say long neck ice cold
beer you guys cold since they're perfect
okay
we're ready first story today is this
story everyone's talking about so we
must give you an update Gigi Hadid and
bachelorette cast off Tyler Cameron hang
out again two nights in a row two nights
in a row supermodel Gigi Hadid and Tyler
Cameron have now hung out twice within a
24 hour period following their Sunday
night out at Brooklyn's Dumbo house
which spilled over to the deets
Manhattan apartment so I was wrong they
did go back to her place but they really
tried to not be caught because I so I
read front page six like how exactly
they tried to get into her apartment her
apartment has a garage they met around
the corner the car picked him up like it
was a whole copper gr and they still got
caught yeah
the pair went bowling Monday evening at
frames bowling lounge in Hell's Kitchen
although Hadid was seen entering and
leaving the venue with friends and not
Tyler and I witness spotted him inside
as well as their group was bowling in
one of the private rooms just days
before Cameron's first night out with
Hadid the florida general contractor was
photographed leading the LA home of new
single Bachelorette Hannah brown which
they need to stop talking about making
it seem like he's like a big player like
that would some a staged photo ever and
he had to pretend like he was cool with
being her runner-up and he wasn't so
like well I watched the after the final
rose of the finale because I wanted to
see this so-called connection between
Hannah and Tyler and why someone like
the snitch would ship them and not Tyler
and Gigi because if you love Tyler like
you should want Gigi for him and not the
woman who didn't pick him right so I
watched it look at women who didn't see
his value right I watch it and he truly
is a precious gem of a man like he
couldn't like be better at saying the
right stuff like couldn't be hotter
truly yeah and when he went out there
and she asked him on a date and he said
yes like it really felt like this wasn't
the first time they had this
conversation and that something like had
been going on and then there was also
speculation that it looks like he wanted
to lean in to kiss her but then like
stops himself I wouldn't say they're
very familiar with each other and then
it's all it's all weird were they acting
in front of us have they been hooking up
like it's all strange as I think things
I we're body language experts
I think Thai Embassy has been like
completely checked out since he lost and
just really focus like I heard he was at
Calvin Klein getting himself a modeling
contract like I think he has absolutely
no regrets about not being picked like
he did what he was supposed to do on TV
to come out looking like a good guy and
he is a good guy and he did what the ABC
network told him to do but like he is so
beyond
forgotten this franchise like he is not
gonna date Hannah like he is on to
bigger and better things and Hannah is
taking a major loss this season like as
if she couldn't have lost worse at her
own season like it just keeps getting
worse
she needs a businessman beau she needs
like an a-rod yeah I really like her and
you were right she's a great
Bachelorette but she really made even
before him having a girlfriend Chad like
she really made the wrong choice yeah
and out of all the guys that would makes
me just question her yeah you know
totally yeah so how do you accept what's
your response to that Stannis sanest I
don't know like because I remember when
I was posed with you and I said I was
like I really think that she's gonna
pick Chad even though I really don't
want her to like I kind of saw coming
and I don't know why but it's like I
feel like we always watch these seasons
and like we always like see these people
pick these people that we don't
understand where I was like I don't see
it I don't understand but we never even
got the chance to understand it because
he was an idiot right that's like Brian
and Rachel like they didn't let us see
their relationship at all and as far as
it looks like they have the most stable
healthy relationship and they're about
to get married and like just from what
ABC told us it's like he was a
consolation prize and that's so not the
case exactly so it's like I just don't I
don't know like because also I'm sure
once everything went down they wanted to
like make everyone like everyone started
hating him right away so I don't say
like editing it I don't know what it was
but we like never I never saw Jen as
being like oh my god like I could love
him but even before it yeah but also
even before the girlfriend thing came
out and she found out about that then
last night what on the finale we were
finding out things that happened while
they were engaged right that were like
not cool right and not saying that she
should have called it off then and there
but like she knew he was not a good guy
they called it off and then went to
Tyler like maybe their things would be
different like Arie and Lauren yeah but
she literally had to wait until the
world would have turned on her if she
didn't break up with yeah right and then
she goes back to Tyler and I just I
actually feel like maybe her and Chad
would get together again no way I don't
think she can even look at him yeah how
can you look at a person when like
everything they've ever said was just
not true yeah and they also were telling
you things I
they were being honest to a point like
to this point when there was like this
much they needed to say so they're so
calculated yeah I literally could not
look at him I could not look at I was
just like you're [ __ ] pathetic with
your music when he showed up to propose
to her with his guitar I literally like
was mice jumping out of my thigh was -
he can't see he literally cannot think
to see I'll forgive him if he does a
cover-up toast she confessed to her
early in the season that she went on the
show for his music and but now he's
really having feelings for her so when
he showed up and played guitar like on
the biggest moment on the biggest stage
yeah I would have been like are you
[ __ ] kidding me right now you're
using me again and that's what it was
and she said it once but like he was
using her the entire time yeah
for press and his sad sad songs sad son
I don't want to lose any more anyway I
say this because I do not ship Hannah
and Tyler and I me neither now people
are saying Tyler might be the bachelor
okay after Harrison like stepped out and
he was like if Tyler's like living in
love in the limelight and you know which
he should do that's not the kind of guy
we want as our bachelor oh my god they
love to like select if they make fun of
people who like live for the fame
everyone even like the good guys in
bachelor nation like live for the fame
Ben Higgins precious gem of a man he's
hosting the new show that they are
growing around regionally dating
bachelors like everyone takes what the
show gives them and they need just have
acting like that's a bad thing
yeah just Tyler might be getting a lot
more he's just getting better face yeah
like Calvin Hein and Gigi Hadid right do
you think that if they offer him the
bachelor that he should be the bachelor
no I think he's a buck I really don't
think that he can be the bachelor
anymore because it's always like that
it's a conversation if like is he ready
I don't think so cuz he's busy dating
other people but I can really see like
in two years like honestly like him
being one of the biggest male models in
the world yeah like he is just so
[ __ ] hot it's like classic American
bad-boy next time and if Calvin Klein
picks him up like which they're saying
that that he's going to like I could
just see him on billboards and underwear
like Oh like I can really I can picture
like this have being like the biggest
springboard for his modeling career like
him just being like um who's like a like
a viral male not oh not viral like like
a Tom Brady looking like just like
all-american like Tommy Hilfiger Tommy
Hilfiger
yeah I could see him on the back of a
horse I'm not familiar with the male
model I'm not familiar with one male
model no me neither
I can't except for a hot felon hot felon
he's hot yeah whatever I could just see
it like really also when you are the
bachelor like you probably come out okay
but everyone hates you along the way
like he's in a great place but then you
think about like Peter Krause who's kind
of in the exact same position like
beloved should iki Bella should he be
The Bachelor what is he gonna do next
he's going out on a high but he actually
I think in my opinion is one of those
few people who like actually doesn't
want the fade look he enjoys a success
like his business has grown so much
because of the show and he owns that and
like leans into that but I don't think
he really wanted ever to like be on TV
and be more famous um
Chelsea worth it he's the next Smith
Jerrod yes that's exactly what it is the
face of AB the absolute hug
yeah great comparison okay I love that
for him anyways back to him and Gigi
there it's happening you guys it's
happening the next Derek Zoolander Thank
You Spencer lady I can't believe two
dates and 24 hours like they're smitten
yeah but that's what are they good or
bad cuz you can burn out too fast 100% I
don't know that it's the great love of
our time but they're smitten the date
went with so house went well right right
or what we're all talking about it and
they still want to go out again right
and Margo that's a good call what if
what if this is not the greatest love
story ever told like what if like she's
like taking him under her wing and like
gonna help get him signed with Lewis
yeah from IMG like you know what I mean
like maybe she's being his mentor what
if they like are like model friends yeah
as opposed to like being she's gonna get
like a back-end Commission from like all
the work he does that make a good
business move yeah but then they're both
like beautiful sweet people why wouldn't
they be falling in love right maybe the
connection wasn't there and then they
really could be friends and then she was
like look help you move it like they're
both but they're I could see them being
together like penny wise okay you too
but also Jesus is smart businesswoman
this could also just be like a real a
real arrangement I don't know I'm I'm
following this closely and I'm
I should so Tyler doesn't live in New
York where is he staying he like his
stay on his friends couch on the like
Upper West Side how do you know that
because he said that it on Nick miles
podcast okay okay friend's couch
friend's couch
futon account I think he's looking for
apartments he's gonna need to get his
own place
Wow she's doubling some real
entrepreneur in the real estate world
she just hit him up and started helping
him apartment hub yeah
shop not hub like Gigi deserves better
than friends couch
I agree Gigi Gigi can't be taken back to
a friend's couch no she did not know
Gigi like truly lives in a palace yeah
okay when they go out who do you think
pays ooh well he yeah look they're not
going out to like five-star I had a
Michelin restaurant no house logistics
up at all like she has to give her
member card yes four member card and
credit card yet and so she would
obviously give her member card and then
is she gonna say and your credit card or
no he would just give his credit card
but he might not like my no no this
standard procedures yeah and she goes to
give a car in it but it's just her
member card anything she's paying oh my
god the logistics I can't stress enough
how bad of a place no house is to take
on a date if not both people are members
it's too awkward it's you are the
logistics of a date are so painful like
when I only been on one date in my life
and I was not 21 and I went to a bar and
like I'd have pain in my stomach the
entire time like how awkward would that
have been like I'm with Ben and I like
him and like I don't get it to the bar
cuz I'm such a loser and like we've to
go find someplace else find a table like
check and cheese torture yes like the
logistics of a date are horrible and for
you to set up a date at a really legit
eclis negative place must be you're like
the most confident person in the world
if anyone's gonna be the most confident
person in GG and it's gonna be Tyler
like he's Jon Hamm and 30 broccoli he
shows up to places maybe they take care
of the check as they've enjoyed looking
at him right and they really got so much
good press do you think Gigi didn't get
some bill I was added to that I feel
like she doesn't get a bill yeah no I
think she does maybe the people at snow
house were like so aware of like how big
of a deal this was that they were just
like it's on us we don't want it to be
awkward I I'm not gonna start like
slamming the service itself house but I
don't know if that's possible yeah well
I actually got an interesting DM because
we were talking about how like super
famous people and like so house
memberships it's like just because
you're cool like sometimes you could be
too famous from a girl who used to work
at so house and she said Gigi at the
time when she was working in New York
was not a member and she used to come
all the time with Joe Jonas who is a
member
God but maybe she has since become a
member I'm sure yeah cuz I think Tyler's
a member she probably enjoyed her time
there and
Joe like moved on so she got her own
membership
yeah it's me it's tough one like the
person you lean on like takes your
membership you know yeah but I think
that makes the break-up like that much
harder it's like now I lost love of my
life and like I also can't go to so
house yeah but at least she got it and
she definitely under 27 like yeah and
they went on oh no a Sunday actually
Sunday's after 5:00 50% off well I see
Jesus rich it was a discounted meal I
just come to take I kid
I can't okay next 7 some more young love
news then I'm skeptical about Ariana
Grande is dating social houses
Mikey foster I've never heard this
before you I think she really tweeted no
I'm not but then today page six is
reporting that she is and now I'm like
okay she released a song with him called
boyfriend I think she's trying to tell
us he's her boyfriend right this is like
when lil nas on his album cover like had
him riding towards a building that was a
pride flag and then like nobody got it
that he was coming out and he came out
he's like I literally told you guys and
so in this instance I would feel like
she's literally telling us except a few
weeks ago someone reported that she was
dating him and she quote tweeted and she
was like actually you know what I
screenshot of the tweet cuz I thought it
was so hilarious maybe she wasn't back
then and it's now they work together
without love but it wasn't very long ago
look I'll see Tyler G I find the
screenshot ladies and I feel like when
you first started dating someone like
that first two weeks like [ __ ] happen so
fast like next thing you know you're
moving in together yeah
and we know Ariana Moe's house she does
she does but hopefully she's maybe
learned her lesson
here it is Cosmo tweeted confirmed
ariana grande and social houses Mikey
foster are dating and she quote tweeted
in and said damn y'all really said
confirmed and he and no one's confirmed
in the same article tight anyway but
maybe she was to the by the way that
actually doesn't that's all he's going
after their reporting yes yes because
they said confirmed and then the article
had actually no physical confirmation
and that was three days ago
so maybe it's the regatta that's not a
rebuttal we actually read that article
and I thought the exact same things that
the title said confirmed that I clicked
I was like oh they have to know
something and it was like people are
expecting the journalism these days you
need degree so she was just calling out
there like journalistic integrity but
not deny
this is like the same level of confusion
as like : Lily like calling out
journalists but not really telling us
what they're calling out or what how
they actually stands but also on that
drive they are together if anybody saw
Lily's birthday post for call yes a poem
so I really care about them yeah but I
feel like now we have our answer
ya know and I'm happy but it's bad yeah
I I sleep better at night knowing you're
sleep better yes we're at the end sleeps
status leaves there's that's so crazy to
be a scientist because there's so much I
could keep you up just about what other
people why do you think it takes me
forever to go to bed and you have no
control over it I know what's called
anxiety and you can't even like give
them advice like you're they're your
friends they don't listen to me they
don't listen to you they don't even see
me I think you need okay well you know
what I think it's time for Ari
to be in love again you know I feel like
she spent so much time working on
herself she seems like she's in a good
place but also like she is the pop star
and I know it's hard when when you're
that famous like she's arguably well she
is probably top 5 most talented pop
stars of our time in terms of vocal
ability and also her level of fame is
just astronomical and there's no stop
there's no end in sight number one most
solid person on Instagram yeah Oh is she
no Christian I'll Cristiano
I think she's number two she's up there
and like I don't know I don't know him
it seems like he's really like
piggybacking on her fame I've never
heard of social house they are her
concert openers yeah headliner Oh cute
actually yeah and you know what very
stable very stable so she's able to tour
because apparently she can't stop and
she's got her man with her okay I spoke
too soon we went to the concert and we
missed the opener so that makes sense
yeah oh but we were in the room with
them in that um we were in the room yeah
I think you guys had went to get tequila
but they sounds like something they came
in after their opening and everyone was
like oh my god and I was like I guess
that's the opener okay they were really
cute and they were really nice to
everyone
that's nice love that like lucky indeed
like Gigi ADIZ nice on set yes on set so
I ship that's two ships today coming in
my ship is coming in speaking of
housewives storehouses of Orange County
is back tonight and it's the first
season Vicki Gunvalson is not a
housewife I'm really interested to see
how they label her friend of Tamra
friend of town that is so low yeah like
she brought Tamra onto the show and made
Tamra what she is but you know it's
gonna be a good season because he
have something to prove just like next
season of Beverly Hills is gonna be
great because these women have something
to prove but they also have something to
prove being like about Vicky actually
got demoted that means any one of us are
fair game for demotion and by the way it
is the season of Shannon beador and
that's hot it is hot girl summer for
Shannon beador as a Shannon Stan you
have bananas I shed a stand-in I've been
waiting for this day and I sat here and
I took it for so long defending her
blindly you didn't and so this is my
time okay let us down Shannon it I
really hope she doesn't let us down
because while she's looking her best and
her life seems to be really in a good
place I just hope that a rational like
sense of logic that she uses when
arguing with people for no reason I hope
that's gone away I think it has because
that was coming from her anger yes and
her like self doubt yeah so it seems as
though those things are dissipating okay
and we're getting a blooming Shannon
beador
she's in full bloom full bloom do you
know who Shannon beador is counselor I
know like I know the name like I know
she's a housewife but like what's it
she's in a lineup
what sitting I'm assuming Orange County
oh yeah but if she's put in the lineup
no I know okay okay
next more housewives news that I thought
was so interesting and important Denise
Richards things fans after they point
out her enlarged thyroid what Denise
Richards health is improving thanks to
her Real Housewives of Beverly Hills
fans the former fashion model revealed
that after appearing in the season 9
reunion viewers were quick to point out
that her side worried didn't look quite
right okay no before we finish what
where is your thyroid oh like your jaw
no Roenicke throat okay quote a few to
point out after the Beverly Hills
reading and that my thyroid was enlarged
she wrote on Instagram Sunday you were
right it was something I ignored until
pointed out she added I think all of you
who sent me messages hashtag health care
the TV personality is now taking steps
to take care of her thyroid issue
revealing that she has stopped eating
gluten quota it's amazing to me in a
short time eliminating gluten from my
diet how much my thyroid has changed I
had no idea how much our diet can really
affect our body and for me how toxic
gluten really is thank God I don't have
that problem because I love gluten but I
just think that's so crazy that's not
the first time I've heard of something
like this where someone noticed
something on a show and told like
the person and they got it checked out
and apparently it was like dangerous
that's crazy yeah I wish I could
remember the benefits of reality
television
yeah the benefits surely no and that's
like people helping clear just love
Denise Richards like I just want her to
have a long prosperous life and career
she's in the 902 Oh No reboot which I
think will be great for her acting
career I just think like all of Denise
Richards chips are coming in they're
coming in she's info bloom as well she
is in full bloom as well and I don't
think she realized that the housewives
might actually be helpful in blooming
other things I think that like when you
are like a true celebrity actress like
you think of things like this is a step
down you have to really the house place
franchise is so much more elevated than
it used to be and Beverly Hills
especially like certain joining certain
castes like could be sad but joining
Beverly Hills is definitely a more
prestigious of the franchises and I
think that shockingly to Denise's
surprise this has been so good for on
all fronts health marriage career her
ship is coming in money for Monday
dollars can use that four million
dollars for two seasons so at least we
know we have her at least for another
season yeah I think was more than are
you sure with two seasons I think well
anyway she didn't hurt every penny and
yeah that's contradicting what I used to
say no I just love the thing about how
science is it really shows you like how
people a can change and people aren't
always not what they seem like I'll
never forget the first time we
interviewed Lee Anne when we thought she
was crazy and she literally was so nice
to us like why don't you go out for
drinks like couldn't have been cooler
more later well it's just like you think
you know someone but you don't yeah also
the other person I was talking about who
was diagnosed on TV Tarek el Moussa
apparently had a cancerous thing that a
nurse saw on his show yes I got pointed
it out and then he found out interesting
interesting
I see I stood behind him in an airport
once I'm like I was truly star stir I
was there too and like he was really I
thought Yugi couldn't we couldn't place
in that person so I was just at Oh movie
star but then reality star but he really
looks like a movie he's like a big guy
yeah he has a presence about it and he
was nice to everyone on set speaking of
house shows I watched with it like this
ik which I meant to talk about yesterday
and it's got potential okay it really
does I
like the houses that they're viewing and
you know I'm not big into home shows but
I might use house was the first episode
they're doing famous people right not
only famous people they're flipping like
luxury properties and making them like
just one of a kind of dream houses so
they did that with like one sad house
they made it like not sad family houses
per episode there was to this happen it
was one house that they finished one
they're looking for their next one got
it and then they also did a bedroom in
Steve Aoki's house that was cool which
was really cool and every I think it's a
great I think they've got a great team
I'm nothing it's great that they finally
have like a home show on a like that
they have too many it's a good one it's
with a Kardashians star it's simply a
good formula yeah my issue is that is
the decor that will afford is bringing I
just wanna be bad make that look so good
is so not my vibe it's like very like
anthropology you know understated
understated very California so many like
plants in the room and also a lot of
things on the floor and on the tables
that don't do anything you know and I'm
that's not for me so so much time she's
saying like it's a contrast between like
these masculine modern homes with like a
more homey feel but it's we've got to
tone it down on the greenery yes that's
a problem I have with like a lot of HGTV
shows is like they're it's cool to watch
like the renovations but like never once
what I actually want my house to look
like that it's like Fargo sits rustic
like what happens just like modern
comfortable furniture yeah big nothing I
agree it was it was too much but you
know they'll find there they'll find
their wicker chairs like no I need to
just check every single chair was like
worse looking than the net and it's not
able to be sad and all the rugs were
like straw you know yeah that's so not
my vibe so not my vibe and Scott's
partner Benny is a little annoying but I
think I could come around okay you know
he just is coming off strong and like
obnoxious and it's also like the first
day of filming like he might not know
like what his place is in the show Scott
is strong and I'm noxious and so we need
a different ingredient like to balance
it out that's my favorite thing that
I've gotten from song land it's like
it's too much of one ingredient yeah you
know so that is such a great show I'm
dying
who else has been on I'm behind too but
I just watched you episode people that I
like oh a six-hour black I don't think
there's been an episode was the best
episode they really yeah they were
looking for a song for the soundtrack
for Hobbs and sha they knew
passing career was probably answered
look the episode was proudly sponsored
by the movie that would be smart but
yeah it didn't seem like it didn't see
it was they put the director and Alaa
black were there 100%
that's good advertising almost as good
as a morning toast advertisement Oh are
we glad to get one no yeah I want one
okay today's episode is brought to you
also by attitude which is a brand new
company sheets and I have recently
changed my sheets attitude maybe a week
ago and I just have to say I'm now
sleeping with pants because I didn't
realize how much your sheets can affect
your temperature and I guess I had like
bad non-breathable sheets before and now
I just feel so cool at all times which
is truly a game changer attitude is
feathery soft sheets if you want to get
the best sleep of your life you've got
to try attitude it's different from
other sheets they do not in there
deliver oh my god sorry I can't talk I
have a frog in my throat give me a
second so they have comfort cooling
antimicrobial and they're better for the
environment the cooling element is
really what got me there organic bamboo
lyocell is extremely breathable it
regulates your temperature to improve
your quality of sleep and they're also
better for the environment because they
organic bamboo lyocell recycles 98% of
the water it uses so it's the most
sustainable bedding available cotton
uses a ton of pesticides and waste water
and it's harmful for the environment I
never thought about my sheets as being
like a harmful for the environment or be
like not good for me like chemicals it's
like the same on tampons like you know
what be your I spend so much time in my
bed like I want a 98% organic
sustainable sheets you spend the most
amount of time probably I mean so do I
in your bed yeah you need to be thinking
about while you're putting on your body
the amazing sheets of a 30-day risk-free
trial if you're not fully satisfied you
can return your sheets for a full refund
and they even cover the shipping returns
the bedding is for the educated
conscious consumer a hundred percent
organic bamboo made with non-toxic
manufacturing process it's
hypoallergenic and antimicrobial and I
definitely feel as though Theo has been
enjoying them that's the true test he
likes he has a coat of fur on like he
likes to be cool when he sleeps and he
has been sprawling out on the sheets
like spread legs spread spread em spread
em attitude sheets they're softest silk
breathable is linen but at the price of
cotton you're gonna love them and when
you support our sponsors you support our
show our listeners we got 20% off their
sheet set and free shipping text toast
to 79 79 79 the only way to get 20% off
your said
cheat sheets and free shipping is to
text TOA st to seven nine seven nine
seven nine again text toast to 79 79 79
message and data rates they may apply
they may I love it and I just can't when
I think of attitude I can't help think
of we've got that attitude yeah that's a
great name for bread it really is and
they're also great sheets 11 11 make a
wish I wish like night's sleep but oh my
god I really can't talk today I wish
like oh my god I wish for sleeps like
this that's what I was gonna say thank
you so much and attitude is a great
brand that I wouldn't have known about
if not for the toast so honestly I'm
super grateful like to myself no and I
feel like we're getting into really
every category where it's like if you
stick with us man we'll get you set for
life we'll get you set will get you
organic healthy yeah oh and saving money
which is greatest the greatness okay
next story Gwyneth Paltrow is finally
moving in with her husband after a year
of marriage after nearly one year of
marriage when the pouched row is
consciously making a big decision she's
making Brad Falchuk her full-time
roommate yes at long last the duo they
Wed in September 2018 are moving in
together the actress revealed while
speaking with InStyle married life has
been really good she raved and now we're
moving in together this month I adore my
husband he's brilliant and deeply kind I
feel like he's a real equal to and he
pushes me in the best ways I really like
being married it's fun I love them so
much and I'm definitely a Gwyneth
Paltrow apologist because I feel as if
she's been this most misunderstood woman
in Hollywood I'm sure when people like
her there's a she's that like has been
like whatever whatever works I don't
know what it's like to get married when
you have kids and they have kids like
there's a lot of politics like it takes
time when I was reading Howard Stern's
book it's a compilation of some of his
best and favorite interviews and his one
with Gwyneth Paltrow was great for him
because it showed that like he could you
know carry a different type of interview
and it was amazing for her she was so
real and so funny she's the coolest like
it's so weird to me just like that she's
got in this and I you talk about her
positively all the time and everything
you've ever said came off in that and
yeah it's it's like it sucks so like
she's gotten this reputation as being
this like pretentious like and like
whatever yeah she sells 300 on her face
mask some good but there's a market for
it because in reality like I feel as
though she's most misunderstood person
she's literally never been like I met
her once and she remembered me follow me
on Instagram EDM that I had
and she's literally the nicest lady ever
and I've hung out with her and Brad and
first of all the hottest man alive Brad
and so smart like he knew he's so good
in his fields he was smart enough to put
Ben Platt in the Netflix show that's
coming out soon like can't [ __ ] wait
I mean anyone who could give us scream
queens yeah [ __ ] lame oh and by the
way the best part about their love story
is that they met on Glee oh that is the
best part so they're just like such like
a good couple the way they talk about
each other and like first of all they're
both so hot and they like know how hot
each other isn't like really are excited
about the hotness of one another and
they both just like love each other so
much and I just like I'm out here like
truly petitioning and lobbying for quite
a pouch out to be more understood four
addresses for Gwyneth Paltrow's just for
go ahead Paltrow I'm here for that
except after reading her interview I
really ship her and Brad Pitt like they
were Oh what was the Orochi oh my god
they were like just obviously like
Hollywood's golden couple she was saying
that her dad loved him like her dad was
more devastated when they broke up yeah
then she was and he was the one who
defended her to Harvey Weinstein and
he's the only man in Hollywood that we
know of who did something at the time
and risked his own position for her and
she was saying like at the time I really
didn't have I wasn't you know the
actress that I am now I didn't have any
power and Brad used his own power right
she liked his leverage to defend me and
for that like we just we don't
appreciate Brad Pitt enough totally I
didn't know that when was the interview
from what year maybe 2014 she had
consciously uncoupled with Chris Martin
and she explained that too because that
was a phrase that from like some guru
that she had heard where instead of
divorcing like you know after divorce
there's bad time and then you get to a
point where you're okay with each other
and you cope Erin and whatever and she
was like can we just skip to that period
is consciously uncouple but still be no
I'm she's slating they're all make sense
but like also the words are or ice
storms where divorce is like so harsh
I'd like for the kids like they're good
parents of divorce like I get it yeah
anyways I would recommend the interview
because now I see what you see
yeah she's PG um and you know what like
I kind of was here for her not living
with her husband like ice it is a dream
if you're rich enough to have two houses
like when I got there I told bed I'm
like I'm getting my own house with a
hibachi and you are gonna have to live
in the guest house
yeah no but he'll get a house with a
golf simulator and like yeah everyone
will be happy no it's like I could I can
only wish to be that wealthy yeah anyone
here seen once upon a time in Hollywood
no no yet I really am I want to see but
it's sold out everywhere I've tried to
go to the movies now three weeks
weekends in a row and it's like because
the top girls summer like people in New
York just want to stay inside with air
conditioning and movie theaters since
like movies are like a dying industry
like the theaters are now so small we're
like they literally only have 30 seats
yeah and I had literally have not been
able to see Lion King or Once Upon a
Time in Hollywood I'm have to wait till
comes out on DVD yeah we're ready
[ __ ] sad I really want to see it okay
the final story high-end retailer
Barney's files for bankruptcy
Barney's an icon of America's luxury
clothing world for decades has filed for
bankruptcy the new york-based retailer
filed for chapter 11 bankruptcy
protection early Tuesday morning it said
in a statement that had also secured
seventy five million dollars from
affiliates of Hilco global and the
Gordon brothers group to help meet its
financial commitments quote like many in
our industry Barneys New York's
financial person position has been
dramatically impacted by the challenging
retail environment and burn structures
that are excessively high relative to
market demand Barney CEO Daniela Vitali
said in a statement the bankruptcy
filing will allow the company to conduct
a sales process review our current
leases and optimize our operation oh
please this is the least shocking thing
ever me and Marco went to Barney's a
month ago and I literally said like this
store will never last they called
themselves a high-end luxury retail
store they don't carry Chanel Dior duchi
or Louis Vuitton or Fendi no they do
that was one it was one thing they had
and I have had a gift card in my wallet
I want to say for over two years I got
from a gift from a brand that I worked
with a gift card and I never looked at
like how much it was I'm like okay the
next time I'm at Barneys I'll look it up
have I ever been to Barney's no I went
to Barney's a year ago is for $1000 I
walked around the store like all right
I'm gonna get whatever I want I
literally couldn't find one thing that I
liked that was $1000 because it was
either two hundred dollars or ten
million dollars and the stuff was so
ugly like I literally couldn't find
anything that I wanted I literally have
to skip part of free money and I I've
been to Barney's house three times since
I cannot find something to buy no I said
now I have to they're going out of
business watch I go this is really well
no they're not going on business they
filed for chapter 11 which isn't a death
sentence it's like oh restructuring
speaking of chapter 11
Jackie and I were on a call just like
business you know and we said to
ourselves we're like we had a we were
negotiating with this brand and we
haven't heard from them
we're like what happened they seemed
here they say Jackie called found out
they filed for chapter 11 honestly
that's a great reason to not hear back
from a brand not that they like didn't
want to work with you and they thought
you were too controversial no a hundred
percent it's like they're going they're
going through some stuff and Barney's is
going out of business I think they're
closing 15 stores but they have to like
you know get their [ __ ] together and I
really need any advice that's what I was
thinking too but then there's just like
Barney's in place you in New York I know
there's one in LA how are there 15 like
in malls and stuff you know they're not
I'm sorry they're not what they think
they are like they and they have only
expensive things that are like cool and
trendy that won't be cool in a year it's
like if you're gonna spend a lot of
money on something at Bergdorf's like
it's classic it lasts forever like you
could see your investment like Barney's
gets things from Brad's like just popped
up that are like randomly $2,000 sneezes
like definition is like Golden Goose
sneakers yeah like that what's wrong
with Barney's with a $600 sneaker they
send your dollars sneakers that you're
paying for that are pre dirty right they
get in trouble for glorifying poverty
like because they're ripped and torn and
they look like what you would look like
if you couldn't afford a pair of shoes
but they make you pay $600 for them they
won't be cool in five years but you're
the [ __ ] who spent $600 on them
explain I don't know but among the
stores that are being closed are Chicago
Las Vegas and Seattle oh so now New York
no no no no not anymore then New York
one uptown or which one is the flagship
uptown really because I thought the
downtown one was and when they opened it
as like the flagship reopened oh really
but I think when the downtown one went
out the uptown one became the flagship
inter Sun yeah there's something just
stark about the downtown store the
downtown star like you walk in and it's
completely empty you're like where's the
clothing this whole store is aesthetic
is so stupid like this is not chalk wait
no you guys it's time to pivot yeah
pivot and I can't even with the Golden
Goose like totally it enrages me it's
such a dumb concept that's my [ __ ]
cross to bear yeah it's I don't know how
to tell you this but your sister has a
parrot I know but she didn't buy them
someone gave it to you as a gift oh yeah
and I threw them out okay good
so stupid yeah lol uh okay those of you
that size stories that you needed to
know and now for things that you don't
need to know um we're not gonna be kept
bachelor in paradise because we're gonna
do it on this snatchler on Wednesday
did you watch below deck was it on last
night well it was on a ten
I assumed it was a new episode oh I miss
a ghost I was watching literally six
hours in The Bachelor in one night so no
okay and then I had a migraine from all
the bachelors I want the anchor
yeah it looks crazy yeah I had a
migraine - listen I got a migraine as I
was watching The Bachelor bed Michu was
like ringing in my head and I had to
take Advil PM and go to sleep I'm gonna
Advil PM gives me crazy [ __ ] up dreams
like I cannot take it anymore I
literally took Advil PM when I disrupt
because I just like needed to sleep and
I was up all night talking about about
this dream about how I thought Theo was
the reincarnated spirit of our dad I
mean he is sit down it's late it was
like I was a realization I could only
come to while on drugs because then when
I realized it totally is true it's
totally true it's very sober thought of
yours yeah I'm also having like another
battle with my neighbor
you know if I told you about this I have
a neighbor who comes into town like once
every six months he's like like a rich
kid who's I parents have an apartment um
and all he doesn't smoke weed and like
I'm not a narc or anything like it's
cool like I know smoking weed is cool
but like over the window like my entire
it started to smell in my apartment now
it's like Theo if you got asthma like
it's really annoying and like I really
don't like I'm not trying to be like a
loser like so I let it pass but now it's
been like two weeks straight of the
entire hallway and now inside my
apartment stinking so I told the doorman
and they said there was nothing they
could do about it so it left a little
sticky note on his door and I tried to
slide the stick you know underneath the
door but the sticky kept getting stuck
to the floor then it wouldn't slide
underneath and then I heard him coffee
inside I was freaking out so I just
stuck it to the door and ran that was
three days ago the post-its still on the
door like has he seen it is he playing
me I don't know he's definitely seen it
if you heard him in there definitely
doesn't give a [ __ ] and honestly it
sounds like I need to tell his parents
yes thank you send your kitchen in you
are maybe to I don't know go to museums
or Julliard yes and now he's inside he
doesn't leave the house yeah no you need
to get the name of the parents like
right then like a letter a letter put it
in there man I can't stress enough like
how much of an arc I'm not like I think
I don't like I'm not like people like
yell at me cuz they think I'm like a
like a loser like I don't care if you
smoke weed like it's cool but like
please don't infringe on my personal
space you know who are the new Hillary
deaf is what people are saying remember
that story where she got in a fight with
her neighbors cuz they were doing that
was it because they were smoking weed
yeah yeah and she had put a picture but
she took it too far
she put a picture of a kid on his
Instagram and like their address like
she went crazy yeah but you guys have
more
but I'm just I'm trying to be respectful
while also being like you know I'm a
cool I'm a cool young person like I
understand that everyone smokes weed
like it's not a big deal
I actually think his apartment might
even have a terrace like go outside
there's no reason in 2019 you could
smoke weed out of a pen out of the vape
out of a brownie like you could
literally like we should not be having
this problem okay so it's just like an
ongoing problem with my neighbor and I'm
trying to be respectful while also
maintaining my cool factor and not be a
narc well you should have the Omega pick
duty and just leave it outside his door
looking really nice to me it seems like
a little crazier than Hilary Duff I
think that's a good solution just a
smell that really bothers me like Phil
gave him a smell that really bothers so
now I'm using all my expensive [ __ ]
molten Brown spray like spraying Lobby
like that's for when I have guests over
like it's not just to waste on the
hallway so it's like I have people come
over to my house like for meetings I
friends come over like I can't even
think it's me they're lighting up a
doobie yeah
then I'm smoking some delicious coach
the day you got arrested for so go get a
doobie I'm gonna sing if he just came
out and said honestly Claudia I'm sorry
like I just really want a smoke
good doobie I would say okay okay okay
and what if he came out and said like I
have chronic pain and this is the only
thing that helps I would say thank you
for being communicative allow it okay
which is like I knock and he doesn't
answer like he's talking for me cuz it's
paranoid he's smoking okay I understand
I'm sorry no but like it's seriously
like open the window like that's it's
let's literally yet sweet so what's
going on with your neighbor's snitch
I've literally never spoken to them
except the neighbor across to me his
doors always open like every time but
you know I'm like a big floor with lots
of apartments I only have two other
apartments on my floor you don't see
anyone I'm rarely my shoot dogs in your
building - mark was a hot doorman yeah
he said yesterday you know who I know
who yeah I'll tell ya yeah Jack used to
be friends
Hoddy lomani with the swimmer's body
yeah he was definitely a swimmer yeah
death death well I guess that's all she
wrote right I suppose so yeah companies
covered a lot but it's like has any min
an hour we have covered up because we're
holding back for - oh that's true okay
they can have so much to say honestly we
should just go record snatcher right now
some ready to party so now John comes
out tomorrow there's a new episode of
the schvitz that dropped this morning
Ben swears it's the best episode yet and
that's it anything else we need to
promote while we're on it on the air
oh I'm toast by toast out itunes who
follow me on instagram at Jackie O
problems Jackie O Flo is on and pop in
the summer pack is premium as hell and I
recommend it because it's your hot girl
summer and you deserve you were actually
saying yesterday that your summer pack
is our favorite so far yeah amazing
enhanced and Seanie vibes yeah I think
like those five are at the top of me to
preset list right now and I don't go
below them and you I don't need to all
right well thank you for listening to
the morning toast the Millennial morning
show we go live Monday through Friday
10:30 a.m. Eastern Time on YouTube so
make sure to subscribe to youtube give
this video a thumbs up if you listened
to us as a podcast we're also available
as a podcast on iTunes Spotify stitcher
I Heart Radio pretty much anywhere you
can listen to podcast so subscribe leave
our vo five stars about how amazing
stunning and smart we are thank you so
much we love you and we will see you
tomorrow morning 10:30 a.m. Eastern Time
bright and early
you